looks absolutely disgusting that everyone is
applauding, applauding this, a
Nazi and especially the President of
Ukraine in whose veins
Jewish blood flows, a Jew by nationality is
standing and applauding, a
Nazi is not just a
follower of the Nazis, not just an ideological
follower, but a person who
destroyed the Jewish population with his own hands,
he personally destroyed it if
the speaker of the Canadian
parliament says that during the
Second World War this Canadian-
Ukrainian or Ukrainian-
Canadian Nazi fought against the Russians
during the Second World War, he cannot help but
understand that he fought on the side of
Hitler and not on the side of his own
homeland of
Canada or was a fascist
collaborators in any case
fought on the side of the Nazi troops,
let’s say he doesn’t
know this, I in no way want to offend
the feelings of the Canadian people, we treat
Canada no matter what With respect
Especially to the people, but if he doesn’t
know that he
fought against Russia during the war  Hitler and his
minions, then he’s an
idiot. Well, that just means he did
n’t go to school, doesn’t have basic
knowledge. And if he knows that this man
fought on the side of Hitler and calls
him a hero of Ukraine and a hero of Canada, then he’s
a scoundrel
or this or
that